let's discuss the eight worst foods for
your skin so typically if a person has a
skin problem they may go to a
dermatologist right and they get a
diagnosis and then they get a treatment
maybe a some type of steroid cream or
something to reduce inflammation or
maybe they don't they might just cover
up the skin problem with some type of
makeup or use some type of cream or some
type of remedy today I'm going to talk
about some real common
things that people ingest that cause the
problem so then you can avoid it it's
not normal to have all these skin
problems right and so if your
biochemistry is messed up or your
hormones are altered
um the thing to focus on is what you're
inputting into the Machinery into your
body all right so let's start from the
top number one you have low fat foods
okay let me explain this and this
relates to some of the other points as
well but 50
of your cells I'm talking about the
membrane of your cells
especially in the skin are made out of
saturated fat
so we've been told so many times to
avoid saturated fat and we replace those
with other types of fat or go low fat
and that is one way to make your skin
look very unhealthy saturated fat is
totally okay to eat as long as you don't
add all the other things that come with
it like sugars and things like that and
also if you can digest the fat too if
you have your gallbladder removed for
example that might be an issue so in
which case you just have to take some
bile salts but also what is in fat you
have all the fat soluble vitamins which
are really important for your skin you
got vitamin A which is a essential for
your skin you have vitamin D very
important as an anti-inflammatory
vitamin E is an important antioxidant
you have also vitamin K and number two
is of course the obvious sugary Foods if
you have acne and you want to get rid of
your acne
most of the time all you have to do is
get rid of the sugar because the sugar
increases the insulin and Insulin
increases androgens that enlarge your
sebaceous glands the oil glands that are
involved with acne and it includes the
obvious stuff like don't drink your
sugars and I'm not just talking about
sodas I'm talking about like juice like
fruit juices the worst it's just your
pure sugar it's all pasteurized which is
sterilized it's equivalent to drinking a
soda just take a look at a diabetic what
kind of skin do they have they have a
lot of issues with skin not just on
their face but throughout their body in
their lower ankles they have these
little black and blue spots they might
have this pigmentation issue around the
the neck area the folds of underneath
their arms sometimes they have a higher
incidence of polycystic ovarian syndrome
where they have more acne they get a
higher incidence of skin tags brown
spots because of all the oxidation
that's occurring with the high sugars
number three grains and the thing that
they make out of grains called alcohol
some people are going to disagree
they're like oh yeah whole grains are
really good for the skin really so what
part of that grain is good for the skin
is it the gluten that ends up creating
bowel issues that then creates all sorts
of problems with your skin psoriasis
eczema even other autoimmune diseases on
the skin itself you got lectins in these
grains and not to mention they're they
turn in the sugar and and that will
increase the blood sugars and create
those other issues we talked about in
number two grains are also high in
omega-6 fatty acids omega-6 fatty acids
are inflammatory and so they're not good
for your skin they're not good for your
gut your skin is a really good
reflection of your liver if you have
poor skin chances are your liver is not
doing well number four which kind of
relates to number three vegetable oils
now it sounds like you take these
vegetables and you're squeezing them and
making this healthy oil but really it's
a grain seed oils or just seed oils in
general that's how they make the
vegetable oils so that would be the corn
oil the soy oil the canola oil the
cottonseed oil these are really badly
processed they have solvents in them and
they create inflammation of your skin
and they compete for the omega-3 fatty
acids which you need as an
anti-inflammatory because if you look at
like a really important uh food for your
skin people say well salmon you know
things high in Omega three fatty acids
cod liver oil well guess what if you're
taking omega-6 they compete so there's
competition so you're not going to get
the absorption of Omega-3 number five
processed protein as in soy protein
isolates or even hydrolyzed soy protein
now you're going to see on if you do a
search on Google like oh yeah it's
really good for the skin well I know
firsthand just dealing with a lot of
patients who have gone on diets with the
soy protein isolates and you're
consuming something very unnatural a
highly processed
super low-fat plant-based protein that
I've noticed that a person may benefit
from maybe some weight loss but man when
they lose weight they don't look good
dries out their skin their hair they
look older I'm talking about this diet
which is low carb it's called Ideal
Protein they use very poor quality
proteins and that's what soy protein is
it's a lower quality
not very bioavailable protein I mean
maybe it might be good for Animals
certain animals like horses and things
like that if they need more protein
because it's a legume I mean horses are
not carnivore they're vegan and so are
cows and sheep and goats but when humans
start doing this
processed protein powder there's some
side effects if you look at the side
effects from soy protein isolates you
get bloating
skin problems skin allergies headaches
indigestion fluid retention obesity and
I'm not kidding that was one of the side
effects as well as diabetes I mean look
it up very interesting I recommend doing
a quality very natural protein like eggs
Fish seafood grass-fed Meats things like
that but eggs especially the yolk is
really really high in vitamin A it's a
great source of protein do you realize
that there's more protein in the egg
yolk per volume than there is in the egg
white interesting all right number six a
lot of people have skin problems due to
milk and even whey protein powder why
because this milk is meant to grow an
animal and then when you consume it or
products with milk
sometimes those hormones can affect the
sebaceous gland and give you problems
with your acne so milk may be a problem
for you next one on the list is low
antioxidant Foods okay like let's say
you don't consume any vegetables or
you're doing white bread or you're doing
processed food or you're doing junk food
all of those don't have antioxidants and
the antioxidants in the food that
normally comes with healthy food not
just vegetables but even grass-fed Meats
have antioxidants as well all of that
protects the skin against damage like
from the Sun from pollution all these
things and even from eating sugar and
when you're out in the sun and you don't
have enough these antioxidants you might
be at risk for getting uh skin cancer
and more problems with the skin so it's
the antioxidants that protect the skin
and number eight gut Flora destroying
foods that would be like the artificial
sweeteners sterile foods like box Foods
canned foods pasta moisturize you know
juices and other Foods refined Foods
soups things like that things that have
a long shelf life when you destroy the
gut Flora you end up with rosacea that's
that red cheeks and your skin does not
look that great and so your microbes
live on uh fiber and so a wide variety
of different uh plants like salads
combined with protein would be a really
good combination for helping your skin
so the variety of vegetables in your
salad also increase the diversity of
microbes which can help you so when you
have this low-fat process
plant-based protein powder and think
it's really good for your skin
you might want to think twice the skin
does really well on higher amounts of
fat lower amounts of sugar nutrient
dense with lots of phytonutrients now a
couple other things that can really help
your skin I've talked about this in
other videos fasting fasting increases
autophagy autophagy cleans out the old
damaged cells of your body and
rejuvenates your skin and other tissues
in the body fasting also increases the
diversity of your microbiome which is
interesting the sun is good for the skin
as long as you don't get burnt you need
that vitamin D for the skin and if you
ever see people that don't get any sun
the skin does not look that healthy so
you want to get some sun but not to the
point of being burned cod liver oil is
my go-to supplement it has not just
vitamin A which is essential for the
skin but omega-3 as well and vitamin D
all together whereas fish oils don't
have the vitamin A only the omega-3
fatty acids stress reduction very
important I have noticed people have
skin problems just by going through a
lot of chronic stress so do what you can
to eliminate the stress and also to
counter that I would do more exercise as
well that can help release a lot of the
built up stress that you have and of
course the obvious things like decrease
smoking smokers usually have aged skin
and people who drink even the wine it
ages the skin prematurely so this should
give you a good starting point to really
have healthy vibrant skin so you don't
end up at the dermatologist's office and
you don't have to cover up different
skin problems now I have another video
on what foods to eat to prevent wrinkles
and if you haven't seen that one I put
it up right here check it out